as promised a work-in-progress version
of the first fallout 4 patch has arrived
Bethesda released update version 1.2
point 33 today which is available for
players on PC who have opted in to
receive beta updates the patch
introduces a few new features for
instance the number pad keys are now
available free mapping and the quick
container can be used with remapping
activate and as always there are a
handful of bug fixes and general
stability improvements specifically the
team fixed a crash related to jumping
into water and reloading saved games
Bethesda cautions that this fallout 4
update is non final and suggest you
backup your saved games before opting
into the beta you can do that by
right-clicking the game in your library
go to properties and then betas you can
drop out of the beta at any time in the
same menu last week Bethesda said it was
hard at work addressing the top issues
patches will be released in beta on
Steam first followed by a full release
on PC before finally coming to consoles
generally speaking fallout 4 players can
also look forward to smaller and more
frequent updates rather than a few major
ones no timetable was provided regarding
when this fallout 4 patch will be
released to the world at large but we'll
have that information for you as it's
announced